bagdad en feu des images récurrentes
depuis le 1er octobre dernier et la
pression d'un mouvement de contestation
inédit
le peuple irakiens accusent la classe
politique d'un poupe et ans et de
corruption la nomination d'un nouveau
premier ministre n'a pas suffi à
atténuer la colère de la rue
mohamed alaoui a été choisi samedi pour
former un nouveau gouvernement sur fond
de profondes divisions au sein de la
classe politique irakienne et sous
l'oeil scrutateur des deux alliés de
l'irak les états unis et l'iran eux
mêmes ennemis cette commission est une
grande responsabilité historique
je m'engage devant dieu et aux généreux
peuple irakien à faire de mon mieux pour
servir ce pays et je vous promets que le
sang des manifestants de nos forêts
sécurité ne coulera pas envie les
agresseurs des criminels seront tenus
pour responsables seront traduits en
justice
larmes de l'état ne sera pas retenu pour
le fun larmes de l'état est de protéger
le pain c'est de maintenir les
frontières et de promouvoir la dignité
nationale
une décision qui est loin de faire
l'unanimité au sein du mouvement de
contestation
la rue est partagée tout comme les
citoyens mitigé face à cette élection
mohamed alaoui est rejeté par le peuple
en raison de son expérience politique de
son héritage précédent et parce que les
partis politiques actuels ont soutenu en
tant que citoyens irakiens je soutiens
la nomination de mohamed toufik allawi
au poste de premier ministre
à ce stade car il doit y avoir une
personne occupant le poste de premier
ministre pour conduire le pays à la
sécurité et de peur de semer le chaos
un chaos qui règne maintenant depuis
quatre mois en irak
des manifestations émaillées par des
violences ayant fait plus de 480 morts
une situation qui a alerté la communauté
internationale mais également le grand
ayatollah ali sistani plus hautes
autorités de la majorité des chiites
d'irak
son porte parole a tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé les élections anticipées
doivent être accélérées afin que le
peuple puisse avoir son mot à dire et le
prochain parlement issu de la libre
volonté du peuple et celui qui doit
prendre les mesures nécessaires pour les
réformes et prendre des décisions
fatidique qui déterminent l'avenir du
pays
un défi de taille pour mohamed alaoui
selon la constitution le premier
ministre a un mois pour former son
cabinet qui devra être approuvé par un
vote de confiance au parlement
[Musique]